the gyro can experience no on the
subject of drugs marijuana is obviously
a big issue in this country and we've
seen many states make it recreational
including this one what do you think
could be done and what should be done to
have this across the especially
federally you know I'm there's a guy
that I have on the podcast coming up
soon his name is John Norris and he
wrote a book on the cartels growing
marijuana illegally all over this
country and selling it especially
particularly in California now because
it's a misdemeanor because it's legal
recreationally and selling it with all
sorts of horrible pesticides on it all
sorts of like very in fact deadly
chemicals all of this because it's not
federally legal because we can't have
sanctioned licensed companies doing an
ethical job of growing something that
any responsible law-abiding person
should be able to consume ok um let me
say this when I ran for president for
the Democratic nomination in 2016 I
talked about a broken criminal justice
system which ends up having in the
United States more people in jail than
any other country we have more people in
jail than China does which is a
communist authoritarian country and what
I called for then and I call for now is
the legalization of marijuana in America
right now you have a federal law it's
called the controlled substance act he
has heroin here is marijuana they're at
the same level that is insane heroin is
a killer drug you can argue the plusses
and minuses of marijuana but marijuana
ain't heroin so we have to end and
that's what I will do as president of
the United States I believe we can do
that through executive order and I will
do that second of all what we have now
is number of states that I'm very proud
I talked about during 2016 what seemed
kind of radical the need to legalize the
decriminalize marijuana a very radical
idea four years ago it is spreading all
over the country and plied the way it
blows my mind to drive through Nevada I
think here even California you see signs
corporations buy our marijuana yeah if
four years ago people getting arrested
you do
that right there lives being destroyed
particularly Nevada there was life
sentences given out in the 70s can you
believe that and now you have
corporations selling the damn product
that people went to jail for so I I
think ultimately you know we've got to
legalize marijuana and what's good news
in a sense is some community some cities
are expunging the records so if you were
arrested have a criminal record for
selling marijuana that is being expunged
and that is the right thing to do you
know we can argue about the pluses and
minuses I'm not a great fan of of drugs
other people you know I smoke marijuana
a couple of times didn't do much from
the other people I guess have different
interests a couple times that's right
true it didn't do much for you yeah
maybe getting it was in Vermont no
that's the problem maybe yeah do
something for you well made me cough a
whole lot alright but I got other people
have had different experiences correct
sure yeah I certainly have the other
problem is of course with illegal drugs
comes you get this horrible cycle
particularly in inner cities where you
have people that are incarcerated for
illegal drugs illegal drugs seem to be
the only way out the hard drugs when
we're talking about cocaine and all
these other drugs how how does one stop
that and would you ever consider
legalizing all drugs or decriminalizing
now all drugs not at this point no I
wouldn't but you're touching on a real
tragedy yes and when we talk about
criminal justice in America we have over
two million people in jail they are
disproportionately african-american
Latino and Native American and here's
what I think I think in the wealthiest
country in the history of the world what
we have got to do instead of building
more jails and lock a lot more people we
really do have to invest in our young
people especially young people in
distressed communities what does that
mean
if we can and we can do this with the
proper amount of resources make sure the
kids are not dropping out of school if
you drop out of school today you know
say you drop out in your second or third
year of high school you don't have an
education you don't have any
skills what are you gonna do with your
life and the answer is you may well do
drugs you know or you'll get in trouble
self-destructive activity or destructive
activity and end up in jail it makes so
much more sense from a humane
perspective protecting our people as
well as a financial situation would
spend an eighty billion dollars yet to
invest in these kids what does it mean
it means making sure they get the
education that they need paying
attention having good schools making
sure that they get the jobs that are out
there doing job training there was a
principal in a school in southern
Vermont I'll never forget what she said
was a working-class school and she said
burning I love these kids I am NOT gonna
let them drop out and she had a
mentoring program just watching the kids
who are mostly at-risk so that they
would not end up going through the
cracks and getting into trouble that's
what we should be doing as a nation and
when we do that we invest in the kids we
get them jobs we gonna medication the
likelihood is that the likelihood of
them falling into bad ways is
significantly reduced all those things
sound great the uncomfortable reality
about drugs though is that when drugs
are illegal criminals sell them and
there's obviously a need for drugs in
terms of not necessarily need but a
demand for drugs is it demand for drugs
in this country that's absolutely
fueling Mexican cartels and illegal drug
runners inside this country I mean
there's there's a lot of that how do you
how do you curb that if drugs are
illegal what you're raising a deep
question yes all right so the question
essentially that you're asking is what
is the cause of the opioid epidemic yes
that is one that's one but but the
opioid epidemic is interesting because
there's so much of it that's coming
legally right that's not another cartels
that's the pharmaceutical industry right
but you the heroin is illegal yes all
right now you're asking this is a very
very deep question which we don't talk
about terribly much why is it that so
many of our people are turning to drugs
to alcohol by the way and I don't mean a
drink a night but I mean serious alcohol
problems
and tragically to suicide
we now have for the last three years
something that is a historical never
happened before in modern history and
that is our life expectancy is actually
going down and this is hitting all over
the country but especially hitting rural
areas and what the doctors are saying is
that these are diseases of despair
despair so you're in West Virginia
you're in rural Ohio or anyplace Vermont
anyplace and the job you used to have
earning a decent living is now in China
your kid can't afford to go to college
maybe you can't afford health care
you've got nothing to look forward to
under that scenario drugs become alcohol
becomes a way out and the worst case
it's suicide so I think what we're
talking about is why is this happening
it's often in rural areas in urban as
well and how can we how can we
re-establish hope and optimism in the
American people and that gets back to a
lot of other issues
it means if people have health care is a
right that will certainly play a role in
this thing that walk into the doctor
when they need but it also means that
people need decent jobs that pay them a
living wage that means we have to
rebuild rural America we have to rebuild
it the press communities in urban
America it means that we have to have a
great educational system and people say
oh that's great Bernie that's utopian it
is not utopian this is something that in
the wealthiest country in the history of
the world we can afford and we should be
doing rather than giving creating a
situation where Amazon pays zero in
federal income taxes so to answer your
question there's a deep questioning and
again I'm not here to tell you I have
all the answers but there are a lot of
people out there who are basically
giving up hope and for those people I
guess drugs is is the alternative so
what you're saying essentially is that
if we can do something to mitigate
despair then we'll do something to at
least stop some of the demand for these
easily I believe that is the case look
if I am optimistic if I'm excited about
to work tomorrow and I'm seeing my kid
doing great in school and you know when
I get sick I can go to the doctor's
office and have a sense of community my
downtown is not all boarded up because
businesses have left but we have we have
a community yeah the lightly strong
likelihood is there will be less
diseases of despair and drugs than we
currently sing